let's talk about booze a little bit
specifically how to get booze that's
foamy okay these are the ingredients for
a pisco sour ordinarily you would use an
egg white because an egg white makes
that velvety foam beautiful texture
we're gonna try some a little bit
different which is hummus
well not exactly hummus these are
chickpeas and you use the the water
basically it has the same kind of
proteins and probably starches although
the science isn't clear on this that
will hold together a foam the recipe for
sour is really easy a couple ounces of
pisco absalom and juice 3/4 ounces of
simple syrup its house-made wired simple
syrup I have to admit to some skepticism
about this drink so I got about an ounce
of that I'm going to do what's called a
dry shake first everyone stand back
starting full of
supposedly the shaking aeration also
gets rid of whatever Dean smells in
there
I got one other trick which is get the
last little bit of air into
well alright I mean yeah boom it's
supposed to be able to do a little
decoration
on the top again slightly skeptical but
calm you guys
it doesn't taste like beans it tastes
like Puma to them it's creamy it does
doesn't it supposed to lie I am kind of
impressed actually all right
shot of beans for everybody